for as long as gotham has existed so has
the myth of the quarter vowels
based on teases the secret society is
poised to play a big role in gotham
knights the new game set in the batman
universe from arkham origins developer
wb montreal
but who or what is the court of elves
and why are they to be feared
for the longest time bruce wayne thought
he knew what gotham was
knowledge is his power and his
understanding of the city was crucial to
protecting it
gotham was batman city but what if for
centuries
a secret society had been lingering in
the shadows that batman had made his
home
what if they were stalking him like a
predatory bird
biding their time and waiting for the
perfect moment to strike
what if gotham was their city and it
always had been
the myth of the court of owls has been
passed from one generation to the next
via a nursery rhyme
but where the court of owls that watches
all the time
ruling gotham from a shadowed perch
behind granite
and lime they watch you at your half
they watch you in your bed
speak not a whispered word of them or
they'll send the talon for your head
much of gotham was built by alan wayne
bruce's great great grandfather
in the winter of 1922 allen was found
hysterical in the streets of gotham
warning the police that the 13th hour is
upon them and
their nests are all around the incident
was chalked up to being a result of
allen's aggressive senility
and a strange obsession with the idea
that owls were conspiring against him
alan ultimately met his end when he fell
into the sewers through an open manhole
cover and drowned
he was found weeks later identified only
by the fillings in his teeth
but allen's words were an omen after all
owls don't build their own nests they
locate abandoned ones made by rival
birds and take
them over owls are invaders the core of
owls had been creating nests around
gotham
in buildings set up using the allen
wayne trust for assisting young
architects
it had established a network of unseen
safe havens for over 150 years
and many of them were right under
batman's nose
across those years they ruled the city
and enforced their world from the
shadows
using seemingly immortal chemically
enhanced assassins called talons to do
their dirty work
evidence of the court of all's dates
back to the 1600s
and the infancy of gotham sea the cabal
had been involved in key moments of
history
and had a hand in some of its greatest
upheavals there are even suspicions that
they were involved in controlling the
distribution of power in the sea
bruce wayne noted that after the death
of his parents at the hands of joe
chill he wasn't able to accept that it
had been a random act of violence
instead he believed there was something
bigger happening that he couldn't
identify
days before his parents were murdered
bruce found an owl's nest in his attic
and despite showing them away they would
always return
an older version of the nursery rhyme
mentioned heeding the signs that the
core of owls were watching
and this he thought was their warning to
thomas and martha wayne
young bruce followed the hunch but it
ultimately amounted to nothing
and taught him not to let his emotions
guide his investigations
however when analyzing alan's body he
found that his great great grandfather
also had numerous small puncture wounds
on his body more importantly
his bones had traces of a residue from a
metamorphic rock
just like the nursery rhyme beware the
court or vowels
rolling gotham from a shadowed perch
behind granite
and lime the mysterious court of owls
began its campaign against batman
after bruce wayne revealed plans to
revitalize the city
a major deviation from the court's
long-laid plans
it begins by murdering a gotham citizen
and framing batman's ally
dick grayson aka nightwing for that
crime using his dna
and then proclaiming that bruce wayne
would also meet his
end imminently during a meeting with
mayoral candidate lincoln march
bruce is attacked by a talent named
william cobb
but continues to believe that the
assassin is simply using the legend of
the court of owls
as an advantage however he's forced to
abandon skepticism when he's once again
assaulted by cobb
and pulled into an underground labyrinth
there
looking down on him from above are three
figures
wearing owl masks bruce attempts to play
to his advantage and hide in the shadows
but every turn leads him back to the
center where a towering owl statue bears
down on him
showing him that wherever he goes the
path always leads him back to the core
valves
he finds a room with its walls lined
with pictures of those the court has
used and killed
and the numbers are in the hundreds in
the labyrinth
batman is driven to the brink of madness
he begins to act on emotion
despair starts to creep in as he
realizes gotham is not his city
and it never was the rooftops he bounds
across
on his quest for justice belonged to the
court and the allies he thought he had
were manipulated by them
and all that he knew and believed he was
was what they allowed
batman is believed to be infallible but
he has been broken many times
at the hands of the joker bane and other
villains
the events of the labyrinth however are
arguably his most
thorough defeat he was physically and
mentally bested
and more importantly his entire
understanding of the world as he knew it
was undermined
but each of his defeats have
strengthened batman's resolve
and it's no different in his battle
against the court of owls with the
secret society confirmed as real and
dragged into the spotlight
batman defeats cobb and escapes the
labyrinth vowing to return to root them
out
showing that no one knows gotham like he
does but the court has prepared
they've created an army of warriors
brought back from death and enhanced to
do their bidding
the talons number in the dozens and each
one is sharpened specifically to tear
down batman
as bruce prepares to take on the talons
and the court further revelations show
just how deep the court's influenced ran
it's revealed that william cobb was
actually dick grayson's great
grandfather
more insidious however is that grayson
was also selected to be
italian as the circus his family was
part of delivered child athletes to the
court to serve them
perhaps the court's greatest achievement
was that it shook bruce wayne's faith in
his understanding of the sea
but despite this when the court launched
a full frontal all-out assault on wayne
manor e4
while owls may be the natural predator
of bats bats make their homes in the
depths of darkness that owls are
incapable of reaching
and after being chased away bats always
come back
batman's investigation takes him to the
willow wood home for children which was
established to help children suffering
from mental illness and neurological
disorders
the home operated until a sinkhole
destroyed a portion of it
and in the time following the truths
about the abuse and neglect that
children faced there came to light
there batman once again met lincoln
march who is revealed was a puppet of
the court of owls and knows batman's
true
identity march having turned on the
court was killed by a talent and brought
back to life using the same
magic that allows the talons themselves
to cheat death
the most ground shaking revelation
however comes when march reveals his
real name
thomas wayne jr bruce's brother
born early and with complications thomas
wayne jr
was supposedly put in the care of willow
wood to heal out of the spotlight
his healing took a turn for the worst
however when funds dried up
after the home's biggest donor martha
wayne was killed
the supposed brothers face off with
thomas wayne jr outfitted in an
advanced talent suit he tells bruce that
they were to share the sea
but instead bruce left him to rot and it
was the court that came to save him from
his torment
the battle between them ends with an
explosion in an abandoned building
bruce escapes but his would-be brother
is thought not to have been so lucky
although batman emerges victorious it's
with the knowledge that the court of
owls continues to operate
having suffered a setback the court puts
into motion their plan to recruit a
talent that got away
the grey sun even scarier it's revealed
that the core of owls
was just a small group that is
ultimately part of the parliament of
owls which exists purely to corrupt the
house of wane
the court and the parliament's resources
are vast and their roots in gotham are
deep and strong
the secret society continues to be a
threat and in fact
they are more powerful than most even
realize their centuries-old presence
affords them a unique advantage over
batman
and their wings could engulf gotham once
again at any moment
currently the role the court of owls
will play in gotham knights remains
unclear
but given the extent of their power and
the grip they have on gotham
whatever presence they have will likely
be a formidable obstacle for the bat
family
so there you have it the history of the
court of owls
and why they're to be feared if you want
to talk more batman with me you can find
me on twitter
h i'll see you later bat fans
[Music]